hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my West world episode 3 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet the title was virtue and fortune
so we're starting to see the beginnings
of Teddy versus Dolores like Dolores has
no virtue she throws all those
Confederate O's under the bus but Teddy
does have virtue so he lets the major go
we also finally got back with armistice
who we haven't seen she has a dragon
probably my favorite line from the
episode so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I'm doing Westworld all
season long so top 10 WTF and I'll try
to explain what clues they left for the
end of the timeline because we saw a
whole bunch of flashes in the first
episode this episode paid off a lot of
things especially that Bengal tiger that
we saw from the other Park so number 10
episode starts at this other Dutch East
Indies Park looking place where you have
two people meeting up that are seemingly
real but they test each other with that
crazy sexytime cape let's shoot each
other to see if we're real and I mean it
it totally worked it was one of my
favorite scenes from the episode I love
the misdirect
I love how crazy that woman seemed
although she seemed like the one that
had her head on straight she also has
this sub storyline that's continuing in
what I guess is going to be either next
week's episode or maybe a couple
episodes we don't always check in with
every single character every single
episode but number 9 we find out where
this is in the timeline because they go
to hunt those Bengal tigers which gives
us an idea for oh okay this is where we
are that's where that tiger came from
during episode 1 so starting to connect
the dots but you have to remember that
not everybody revolted in all the
different parks all at the same time
what happens is is because the hosts are
all networked it spreads so it started
in West world with Dolores then like
slowly spread from host to host as they
came in proximity to each other so just
assume this is happening within a day or
two of Dolores killing Ford because you
have to imagine that if there was
something really big going on a West
world they would probably try to keep it
on the DL so even if there was stuff
going on in other parts they probably
wouldn't alert everyone but number 8
this becomes this funny recurring thing
for this woman's storyline out of the
fire into the frying pan so she goes
from like one crazy situation
escapes into another so just as she
escapes those hosts in a twist on that
sexy time game they played at the
beginning of the episode oh don't worry
it's just a fake gun it won't hurt me at
all nope not at all
you are definitely dead now she runs off
and then finds that she's at the mercy
of the Bengal tiger it chases her out of
the park and then we find out how the
tiger washed up on the shore so the
hilarious twist at the end is that it's
just she's climbing out of the river
like aw finally I made it I escaped she
finds herself at the mercy of those
ghost nation people that are sharpening
their knives like you just wonder this
is probably not the last we'll see of
her but it's just hilarious how she goes
from one crazy situation to the next
like oh thank God I escaped that tiger
oh wait there are these people that look
like they might want to skin me or eat
me alive who knows the important thing
to remember too about her storyline is
as the journal she was looking at looked
like it had a map in it there was a
symbol that was drawn that also appeared
when Bernard decoded that big master
file that was stored on Abernathy so
either she's a Della's person looking
for something within the park because
she looked like she was there for some
other reason besides leisure like the
guy was there just to have fun
she was probably there on some special
secret mission it might have something
to do with Abernathy but we'll probably
find out in a couple episodes but number
seven at a place called the cradle which
just looks like an entry point to where
they do a lot of service you find
Charlotte for the first time and it
looks like this is closer to the end of
that two-week period like you you see
all those people marching do you have
what I want no we're still working on it
because they're still looking for the
Abernathy host because Charlotte the way
she talks to Barnard makes it sound like
she knows that he's a host now because
there's a moment in that season 2
trailer where she's looking at all the
different copies of Barnard so at some
point this season she finds out but all
the footage we've seen of her is from
early in that two-week period right
after the revolt we haven't seen her at
the end of that period because the way
she talks about Barnard makes it sound
like she knows like she says do you have
any idea where Abernathy is and it's
almost like this little sinister thing
like something's passing between the two
of them that the other guards don't know
about notice that this version of
Charlotte isn't wearing the vest that
she was wearing later in the episode so
this early version of Charlotte is from
later in the
time line the other version of Charlotte
where she tries to first find the
Abernathy hoes is from earlier in the
timeline but I don't think that they go
further before the end of last week's
episode like that's the earliest point
in time when they're first here up
against Steven augs host that they hack
into which was hilarious that was
actually my number-6 hacking steven hog
making him the most virtuous fastest gun
in the West so it's like a complete
reversal on his character he turns him
from a negan type character just totally
despicable all the way to Teddy who's
supposed to be the most virtuous person
as far as we know so far but number five
we finally catch up with the Abernathy
host and he's obviously got all those
layers of programming on him it's just
like this flimsy collection of
programming to keep him intact so that
he can get on the train and get out of
the park like that's the whole idea I
need to catch my train it's like this
Alice in Wonderland thing where he needs
to get himself there so the Dell O's can
collect him Bernard notes that he's
cycling through previous roles so he
gets to have a different personality
every 20 seconds we even got to see the
cannibal version of him come back from
the end of the pilot episode where he
was quoting poetry talking about eating
people but probably one of the greatest
ways to end a pilot episode ever but the
really important thing about him showing
up in addition to the over plot like
he's got this special information that
Delos wants on how to continue operating
without Ford being around but it's also
the first time that Dolores as Wyatt
shows any genuine sympathy towards any
other host character besides Teddy so
remember the title of the episode virtue
and fortune is it's all about the idea
of Dolores not having any virtue or
Wyatt however you want to think about
her this version of her doesn't care
about anyone like she throws all the
Confederate O's under the bus so her
father is like the one thing besides
Teddy that she really gets pissed about
especially what Charlotte runs off with
him but number four we catch back up
with Maeve Sizemore and Hector who catch
up with armistice while running into
some of the ghost nation soldiers so if
it wasn't clear the ghost nation as a
group of characters are much bigger this
season that's why you saw them a couple
times during the episode they probably
become a much bigger part of the season
next week but Maeve has been flashing
back to her daughter being killed over
and over ever since season one
time we saw it as the man in black
coming to do that but I think those
ghost nation people raiding her home is
just part of what that loop was so that
would happen over and over to her again
and it was just that one time that the
man in black came to do it to test
himself as he said so they're basically
on their way to the homesteads because
Sizemore said that her daughter was at
this same place where her old loop used
to be like she's been here this whole
time okay we'll just go back there and
pick her up but number three on the way
we run back into Armistice for the first
time since the end of last season she
even has this crazy Darth Vader Anakin
Skywalker Luke Skywalker thing going on
where she pulls the glove off she's more
Darth Vader than she is Anakin Skywalker
or Luke but I love the way like you see
Luke and Return of the Jedi
pull that black glove off and you see
the mechanical hand a little bit it's
like a really twisted version of that
and then you have like a real sly Game
of Thrones reference where Hector says
we have a dragon and it's her with the
giant flamethrower I suppose calling
Armistice a dragon would be an apt
description of her character she was one
of the most fun things about the back
half of last season when things really
went off the rails and she started to go
nuts but number two the big battle at
fort forlorn hope so we have Bernard we
have Abernathy we have Dolores and
Dolores throwing everyone under the bus
because she needs to survive the delos
attack that's the only reason she formed
that alliance so imagine a version of
Blackwater during Game of Thrones season
two if Tyrion then turned around and
killed all the soldiers that were
defending King's Landing you get the big
twist with Teddy it seems like it's a
bit of a setup for him to go against
Dolores like Teddy versus Dolores
sometime later in the season because
remember at the end of this two-week
time line we see Bernard standing at
that lake of dead hosts in the water in
one of them is Teddy floating beneath
the surface so early prediction Dolores
says that not everyone is meant to make
it to the next step the place that
Dolores is trying to get to
she might wind up killing Teddy herself
if she deems him not worthy that might
be how he winds up in this lake but if
it wasn't clear the whole episode is
meant to paint her like a villain even
though she has a couple sympathetic
moments with her father number one was
the Shogun world teaser at the end of
the episode they even had the flu
music playing over the credits like oh
this is where we're going next this
makes it sound like it's coming from
Shogun world and these samurais just
wound up mysteriously in the klondike
territory of West world so if it wasn't
clear this snowy area is still in West
world that are in the mountainous area
heading towards the homestead to find
Maeve's daughter but they find hosts
from Shogun world so this part of the
park just probably borders the Shogun
world park which presumably we will go
to next week the big person that they
cast for that storyline too is Rinko
Kikuchi so if you're big fan of that
actress will probably meet her next week
but I didn't see her in the trailer so
we'll see there's gonna be a little bit
of Shogun a world but like there was
that British East Indies Park we'll see
at least as much Shogun world as we saw
of that at the beginning of the episode
so for the most part the show still
takes place in West world the other
parks just spill in two episodes at
certain points but man there's so much
that we could say about this episode so
many good character moments one of the
funnier parts too was when Sizemore got
really upset when mavin Hector started
kissing each other he's like no no
you're not supposed to be together I
didn't write you that way it's not part
of your programming you're supposed to
be with Isabela in mave correctly
deduces this Sizemore wrote that actor
Isabela relationship based on one of his
failed relationships so it's kind of
like him writing fanfiction for himself
and he writes himself looking and acting
like rodrigo santoro so it's just really
hilarious but let me know in the
comments what was your favorite part of
the episode I mean we can talk all about
what's on that secret file that Bernard
started to decode he looked like he was
trying to download some of the files so
he may have copied some of it to himself
but it'll have something to do with the
place that they're going towards in the
weapon that Dolores is probably talking
about in last week's episode there's a
whole bunch of stuff happening next week
so I'll try to get to it as fast as
possible leave all your requests in the
comments below
but click here for my Westworld video
playlist and click here for brand-new
infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]